nicole está por jugar un juego en la
feria del pueblo hay una pared con
platos de losa y el objetivo es romper
los más posibles lanzando un proyectil
suena fascinante nicole tiene
lanzamientos ilimitados durante un lapso
de un minuto por cada plato que rompe
nicole recibe dos fichas cuesta cinco
fichas jugar este juego para que nicole
gane fichas se debe de cumplir la
siguiente desigualdad
es el número de platos que rompen y
coria en qué casos ganarán nicole fichas
pensemos qué es lo que nos están
diciendo aquí aquí tenemos dos por el
número de platos que rompen y col para
ganar fichas nicole debe de obtener más
fichas de las que gasta y por cada plato
que rompe obtiene dos fichas así es que
este número de aquí dos por el nueve
platos que rompe es el número de fichas
que nicole gana pero usa cinco fichas
para jugar así es que si restamos esto
mientras esta cantidad sea mayor que
cero y esto va a ser mayor que cero si
2p es mayor que 5 si obtiene más fichas
de las que gasta efectivamente va a
ganar fichas veamos los diferentes
escenarios y en cuál de estos casos va a
ganar fichas qué pasa si rompe un plato
si rompe un plato va a recibir dos
fichas pero pago cinco fichas así es que
pierde tres fichas menos tres no es
mayor que cero menos tres es menor que
cero
nicole pierde tres fichas
definitivamente este caso no aplica si
rompe dos platos ella recibe dos por 24
fichas pero
va a haber pagado cinco fichas no es una
buena situación para ella tendríamos del
lado izquierdo 45 que es menos 1 lo cual
es menor que cero pero esto lo puede
hacer mentalmente si está recibiendo
cuatro fichas pero pago cinco fichas
definitivamente no está teniendo
ganancia que pasa si rompe tres platos
ella recibe dos por tres seis fichas uso
cinco fichas tiene una ganancia neta de
una ficha este valor es mayor que cero
así es que este caso si funciona y este
último caso es obvio que va a funcionar
si funciona cuando rompe tres platos con
mayor razón va a funcionar va a ganar
más fichas cuando rompe seis platos pero
podemos calcular lo tenemos que ganar
dos por seis doce fichas por romper
platos menos cinco fichas que paga por
jugar ganaría siete fichas que son
definitivamente mayor que cero así es
que este caso también funciona